Học xin và xin viên được vai tối đá bún trở đồng một tháng để chẳng tra chi phí hóc tập và xin hoa phí
Mức này được điều trình gần nhất và năm 2020, nhưng cơ quan sản thảo cho rằng đã không còn khu hợp
ở thực hiện kinh tế sau hội hiện nay khi làm phát, học vi và phí xin hoa đều tăng
Thế buộc ta chính tổng xin hoa phí và học vi qua học xin viên có thể lên tới 18 phẩy mạnh lắm trực đồng một tháng
Mình tắc của trường trình tế giữ trọc xin viên có hoàn cảnh khó khăn là nhà nước phố trở khoảng 17 phần trăm
Tương đường tạm phẩy hàng làm trở đồng. Giờ đó, cơ quan sản thảo để sốt nâng mức trọc vài tối đá gấp đôi hiện tại
lên 18 phẩy mức trọc vài tụi thế, đối với tương trường hợp sẽ gióng lên hàng chính xác xa hội tụi tụi theo học vi tương trường và xin hoa phí tình địa phương
Lại sốt trọc vài hiện hàng của trường trình này là công phẩy nâm phần trăm một tháng
Tương đường xó phần trăm một năm, cơ quan sản thảo dự kiến là sốt mới mằng trọc vài hụng nèo
Lạc công phẩy nâm hàng tình trăm một tháng, tương đường xó phy hàng tư phần trăm một năm
Truy nhiên mức này có thể được điều trình từng thật kì để đạm bảo phố hợp từng hình thực tế
Trường trình tình dụng lượng học xin viên có hoàn cảnh khó khăn
Được thực hiện từ năm hành nghi lệ mời sau 1 chiến năm trên khai
Truy nhiên mời hụi chợh hơn 1 chiều lừa học xin xin viên có hoàn cảnh khó khăn trên cảnh nước